Czar's cough - is the virus that causes
covert 19 the respiratory disease that's
been ravaging the world
the virus is so tiny that it can only be
viewed through an electron microscope
it's about 80 to 120 nanometers in
diameter about one thousandth the width
of an eyelash scientists around the
world have been studying what the virus
does to our cells hoping to better
understand it and eventually defeat it
here's what we know so far by sequencing
people have actually discovered
literally hundreds of crises but the
main lines which affect humans are the
with this seasonal ones the NL 63 the
Hongkong you are there - 290 and then we
have these three moderately severe ones
the SARS the MERS and now this new one
they called Quran because the Latin word
means crown because when people looks at
them using electron microscopy they
found those these little spikes or CRO
or crowns which surrounded the virus now
these spikes are what the virus uses to
attach to cells so not all the crown
viruses structurally look I very much
similar all they different is their
makeup or their genetic material a virus
by and large can't replicate itself it
needs a cell to do it for most viruses
to get into the human body they need
something called receptors the new
corona virus works the same way this
virus uses a receptor which is called
ace 2 stands for angiotensin converting
enzyme - this is a receptor which is
present mainly in respiratory tract and
also in the gastrointestinal tract and
so what happens is that this spike
protein remember that's what gives the
virus its structure the spike protein is
what binds to this h2 receptor the new
corona virus targets specific cells in
our nose mouth eyes gut and intestine
where it can find a stew receptors to
unlock the cell
once the virus enters it hijacks the
cell and turns it into a virus producing
factory it fuses its lipid membrane with
the membrane of the cells and releases
its genetic material called RNA the
infected cell reads the RNA and begins
making proteins that keep the immune
system at bay and proteins that allow
the Assembly of copies of the virus then
the newly assembled copies are carried
to the outer edge of the cell and can go
on to infect other cells within or one
square mark meeting gets 1,600 viral
particles so each cell will can produce
up to about 600,000 viral particles some
viruses when they actually replicate in
the cell they'll kill the cell network
what's called a psychopathic effect and
that can actually then lead to some of
the symptoms but what we've found is
that this virus is not very toxic or not
very it doesn't cause that much of a
psychopathic effect for a long period in
influenza it can start killing the cell
within a couple of days but this virus
has him to not kill the cell for about
five to six days and this means that the
patients may then be having vast
replication but because it's not killing
the cell there can be very few clinical
symptoms and that's why it's been found
that what's called the asymptomatic
carriers but as the infection progresses
many patients develop typical flu
symptoms like fever dry cough and
tiredness as well as atypical symptoms
like a loss of smell and taste this is
the immune system fighting to clear the
virus when the infected person coughs or
sneezes virus containing droplets can be
emitted on nearby people and surfaces
the corona virus can survive on
different surfaces for several hours to
several days but it's vulnerable and
easy to kill many of their common
alcohols and in the bleachers they can
alter the pH and alter the surface or
the outside of this virus which
basically able to disrupt the envelope
therefore not making it in fact
and then there is the environment so
studies which have been done by
colleagues in our institution show that
this virus is actually temperature
sensitive so at 4 degrees Celsius the
virus is can remain very stable for a
very long period of time and 25 degrees
Celsius remains stable for about five
days at 35 degrees stable for one to two
days and at 56 degrees probe at maybe 30
minutes so the warmer the environment
the less stable it is currently there is
no effective treatment for the virus
recovery depends on if the immune system
can develop antibodies to recognize the
virus structure and then destroy the
virus helping fight off the disease and
that's why people talk about the herd
immunity that once you get enough of the
population which has been exposed to the
virus which has the antibodies then that
will then decrease the spread of the
virus from person to person so that's
why some people think that we'll have to
wait until we get enough people becoming
infected that we get their herd immunity
that's going to take a long long period
of time so the alternative is to then
bring in these vaccinations so that if
you can vaccinate people then you can
basically build up hopefully enough
immunity to stop the transmission from
person to person developing a vaccine
that proves safe and effective may take
a year or more medications to fight the
disease may be available sooner but
there's no quick fix to arrest the
pandemic so the only way or potentially
getting this virus under control is
going to be the social ways so for
mechanism which is social distancing
quarantining
and keeping and basically a rigid
attention to personal hygiene and to
your and to the environmental hygiene
many people who have been infected with
kovat 19 have recovered some governments
have suggested that people who have
antibodies to the corona virus could be
issued an immunity passport that would
allow them to travel or return to work
but the World Health Organization has
said catching covert 19 once may not
protect you from getting it again the
use of such immunity pass
ports may increase the risk of continued
transmission
you